Welcome back everyone it's Charlie this will
be my full Rick and Morty season 5 episode 9 video
Even though it was a two-part finale, I'll
do a separate episode 10 video that will post
a couple hours later tonight.
If you're brand-new to the channel, be sure
to subscribe to get all the episodes obviously
there's a bunch of rick and Morty season 6
stuff that they'll be talking about really
soon too I'll do videos for that as well.
Careful for spoilers if you have not seen
episode nine also reference a couple things
from episode 10.
But this will mostly just be about episode
nine.
Even though it was a part of the actual episode
we have to talk about Christopher Lloyd playing
a live action version of rick from this rick
and Morty promo that they did with one of
the actors in the it movie.
This is Jaden Martel he played Bill during
the new it movie all but the whole thing with
Christopher Lloyd being live-action Rick is
that is sort bring of Easter eggs full circle
because doc and mharti Justin Roiland original
precursor for the rick and Morty series was
based on back to the future with Rick being
specifically based on doc brown it's crazy
that they got real life Christopher Lloyd
to do this.
The network also said they originally try
to get Daniel Radcliffe to play the Morty during this
But he turned them down.
Just because he was little too old for the
part she imagine Harry Potter playing a version
of Morty during this will be even crazier.
But they're just meant to be promos they're
not for the actual episodes on number these
as we go along to stay organized starting
with the title of the episode, forgetting
Sarah Marshall, which is a reference to the
movie, forgetting Sarah Marshall where the
protagonist tries to get over this bad breakup
and gets into a new relationship Rick and
Morty have a breakup during the episode, they
both try to start new psychic relationships.
They also heavily reference the dark Crystal
movie with the skin exists in the actual dark
Crystal itself with the crows Rick into crows
forever.
You can also call this episode.
The tragedy of garbage goober.
But the episode starts with Morty going around
cleaning up after Rick on previous adventure
showing the true consequences of what Rick's
actions are and how he leaves this wake of
total destruction it makes it seem like he
doesn't actually care about any of the people
he encounters during his adventures.
This is obviously setting up a lot of the
big reveals that evil Morty drops the big
bombshells during episode 10 the finale they
start in the cookie theme planet.
Which is meant to be a parody of the candy
kingdom from adventure time.
Justin Roiland did a lot of work on adventure
time.
The rick and Morty people are also friends
in real life with the adventure time people
so this is like the darkest timeline version
of the adventure time.
Candy kingdom were a bunch of candy terrorists
have overrun the government and are gonna
kill the cookie president executing him on
live television, which is also a candy themed
television camera Morty whips out the list
of planets that is going to it does seem like
he does stuff like this on the regular next
step is water city there spider bought lava
crystal tip jar is a nuclear worm return conch
being hordes and moon gremlin all these are
references to the different types of disasters
on the different planets that he asked to
undo the second planet he goes to his the
water city with the fish people whose city
is flooding because Rick crashed his ship
through the dam those holding back their ocean.
Then he says another planet from a lava creature
and you probably recognize this is a big Disney
mow on a parody in the water of the lava creature
becomes this big monsters villain after its
heart is stolen, so they're saying that Rick
stole the lava creature special Jim and then
it started rampaging when Morty goes back,
he pulls the old liquor bottle trick with
Rick's portal gun and Mountain Dew a bunch
of you have probably done something like this
at some point when you were teenagers.
Like a lot of people's parents marked their
liquor bottles if you drink from them.
You have to refill the bottles with fluid
that look the same color to make it seem like
nobody had been drinking anything that's also
meant to foreshadow evil Morty hacking the
citadel of ricks portal guns with altered
portal fluid in the finale.
Even though the portal gun says that weird
fluid is a good thing Rick claims that if
he used it this way with the Mountain Dew
in it.
He might've transported his lips right off
of his body.
This is all obviously setting up the whole
b-storyline with Morty in Nick the crazy man
who tried to steal Rick's portal gun from
the bar made claims that before his portal
was connected to mortys portal he was just
using it as a stash whole to throw away his
trash Rick then reveals garbage goober who
that she pretty funny character creature that
he just uses like a living Roomba to Hoover
up trash summer winds up using it to during
the post credit scene.
I guess the whole family uses it around the
house all the time for just all kinds of random
stuff but they turn it into this way bigger
tragic arc during the episode.
Like garbage goober is a Harvard educated
physician but he's been reduced to Rick's
living garbage can in his wife even makes
him a regular spaghetti dinner then Rick fires
Morty interrupt salt in the wound pulls out
that wheel of fortune game to pick his new
psychic later the ravens literally call this
joke out for being lame.
Like we get it is a simple joke you're trying
to say that Morty so dumb the to ravens could replace him
Therefore the ravens are also kind of dumb.
But we just taught you empathy like 10 minutes
ago.
Because is a two-part finale.
The whole idea of the ravens being more intelligent
than Rick kind of them and they kind of work
because he did wind up outsmarting them by
the end of the episode is also meant to be
in service of the idea that the central finite
curve is only an area of the multiverse where
Rick's are supreme.
So there other universes out there in the
larger multiverse where Rick is not the smartest
person it turns out that ravens are way more
cosmic race in the multiverse than you ever
thought but all the other pics for psychics
on his will all the other options start with
Jerry and I love that it says in parentheses
spin again because there's no way that he
still a Jerry be a psychic Kyle 2.0 is a reference
to Kyle.
Who was mentioned by Mr. Nimbus during Season
5 episode one, the person who was supposedly
Rick sidekick before this version of Morty.
They imply that Kyle had died at some point.
But I hope that Nick the crazy person in this
episode would wind up being a version of Kyle,
but no luck there.
There's a bag of meat like a literal not living
simple bag of meat half of a Paul Giamatti
which I think is another callback to season
four with the train conductor who was played
by Paul Giamatti the old man with the crazy
abs one of the options is just a sentiment
piece of crap, there's gene with donkey brains
Jean is their neighbor he showed up or been
reference several times this season already
there is a two crows which Rick lands on and
then there's the garbage goober is an option
which they use for another joke later when
it tries to manipulate the wheel to make itself
Rick's new psychic like not now garbage goober
they left this whole b-storyline with Morty
in the mental patient Nick play out for a
long time before revealing the twist.
Even though he's telling the truth.
Mostly about how more needs to break free
of the abusive relationship with Rick leave
it all behind even tells him not to come find
him.
But eventually, it's revealed that he's gas
lighting Morty this whole time just kind of
manipulating him so that he can get his hands
on Rick's technology and be just like Rick
or he thinks that it will make him just like
Rick if he has Rick's technology they plan
this big joke about Rick training the crows
to set up the gag with the hyper intelligent
race of crows based on the dark Crystal 60s
instead of the bird Quaaludes joke that they
pay off at the end of the episode with the
psychics becoming super of all the Crow people
and helping them because it seems like they're
doing this just for the drugs and as a rebound
from their last relationship as we find out
in episode 10.
Like Rick was using them as a rebound for
Morty.
But they were using him as a rebound for crows
scare they also set up the bird on a wire
joke, which is part of that big and twist
to in the context of the episode.
The phrase bird on a wire is also a metaphor
for Rick and Morty's whole relationship originally
that phrase was a reference to the practice
of putting lime on wire fences or crating
wire traps to trap songbirds and the birds
would seeing trying to escape.
But doing so in vain like to be unable to
escape.
So in the episode, Morty attempts to break
free from Rick and Rick attempts to break
free from Morty.
But neither one of them are successful find
that Rick turned Morty's bicycle into a mini
spaceship so that he could have solo adventures
that the avengers were just meant to be him
doing Rick's common errands notice Morty spaceship
also shares the same design language as rick
ship is also built out of garbage in common
household items.
Even though they have the joke about the carbon
chamber catapult that Rick uses to throw people
Morty says that Rick uses all the time.
That's how they lost their cable guy is meant
to be a different weapon then the bank vacuum
tubes that he uses later to send the crows
to the Crow planet the whole thing with the
mental hospital here is just meant to be a
reference to the mental hospital from Terminator
two with Sarah Connor when he references the
guards beating them up on certain days, but
is not as bad as the other days because on
the other days they lick our faces will were
tied down civil wasn't clear this whole time.
They could just playing Morty to get him to
release him allowed to get his hands on Rick's
portal gun the Jackie Chan reference with
them kicking the crap out of the guards using
their portal connection is just referencing
pretty much all of Jackie Chan's crazy fight
scenes in his movies really any movie he's
ever done with qualified although Nick kind
of turns into more of a rush-hour movie Easter
egg because he mentions Chris Tucker from
the rush-hour movies Rick winds up using the
two crows to pull an Indiana Jones and the
Raiders the lost Ark adventure with the idle
but then playing it is a joke about the real
treasure being empathy which they pay off
at the end of the episode where Rick says
man though to some empathetic crows Rick then
learns about the super advanced crows when
he tries to fire his crows to leave them on
the planet of highly advanced bird cultures
the other joke here too is that when he says
working under him for a day will make them
like apex geniuses compared to the other birds
on the planet.
It winds up being true his two crows sidekicks
eventually outsmart the hyper intelligence
kicks is birds.
This is also at least the second time another
race has had technology advanced enough to trap rick
like this the last time being the time dilation
race that Morty started the war with over
the wine everyone is probably seen the dark
Crystal so you know all about this Texas references
with the castle from the series.
But if you didn't know the lower of the dark
Crystal story in their universe is actually
a combination of science fiction and fantasy
kind of like Star Wars because this Texas
were created when a highly advanced spacefaring
race sought to of all themselves even more.
But wound up using their giant Crystal to
split themselves into different aspects this
Texas and the mystics so their whole castle
and everything in it is super advanced technology
that just looks like a typical fantasy genre
castle that whole psychobabble speech about
not needing to train the crows and getting
on the same wavelength is just meant to be
a metaphor for him dealing with his relationship
problems with Morty like getting in touch
with his emotions in a way that Rick always
refuses to do it kind of turns into a star
wars use the force kind of thing with him
just getting giving into the power of the
crows in a cosmic way it allows them to work
together is a much more effective team, which
itself was sort of a metaphor for relationships
in general Rick kind of calls this out during
episode 10 the finale to reset.
So this is all clearly metaphor for relationships
when Nick and Morty break back into the garage,
Morty reveals that Rick had trapped them in
a version of the matrix before the gun Nick,
winds up stealing also kind of seems like
a video game gun.
If you think you know which one is referencing
right them blown the comments.
Because usually all the guns on rick and Morty
are references to videogame guns.
I also think this is the first time I've seen
someone on the show pickup Rick's Morningstar
that's been sitting on the shelf here since
the very beginning of the show they start
wrecking the garage with Jerry using the but
gun to cover the place in farting butts obviously
Jerry's really excited here because he still
kind of hates Rick but turns himself into
a puddle that they kind of ignore for the
rest of the episode, they still an early prototype
of Rick's portal gun.
This also helps foreshadow the montage of
rick's backstory during the finale when you
see him creating his portal guns and try to
track down the version of rick who killed
his wife and the original Beth because remember
they reveal earlier this season that he was
a Rick who moved in with some other ricks
abandoned Beth.
The whole design of the sexes ship when they
show up, seems very familiar but I can't remember which character
this is a reference to.
So if you think you know the reference.
Please write a blown the comments.
I love the way how rick refers to their house
is the one with the poop brown roof very specific
the only weird thing during this episode.
Normally this lot a weird stuff and Rick and
Morty episodes.
But the weirdest thing here was when they
use the classic comedy slide whistle reaction
noise when they open the garage door like
that feels like some crazy deep cut from a
British comedy TV show from back in the 80s
the crows call him out for being an ass hole
for using the wheel they turn all crows nearby
against humans the wall.
That's going off the rails Morty and Nick
take the family's car which Rick ought also
upgraded into a spaceship previously to capture
a person who supplies Rick with crystals that
he uses to create his portal gun fluid.
It wasn't clear here.
The aliens explained to them that they themselves
did not create the actual portal fluid themselves.
They just harvested the crystals used to make
the fluid and because they want to wrap the
Nick storyline up during this episode and
not spill into the next episode he goes off
the rails superquick he reveals the truth
about who he really is.
He was just a crazy person who sat near rick
at a local bar and just heard his adventure
stories while he was getting drunk and tried
to steal his portal gun one night just became
obsessed with them.
Probably the most thing from this whole third
act climax with Morty here is him choppy his
hand off using the train to kill Nick by sucking
him into a sort of paradoxical portal loop
the collapse on itself.
When Rick is running around the sexes ship
making all the dark Crystal references when
the alarm goes off and he says is anything
here not on theme what he means is during
the dark Crystal movie.
This Texas castle had an alarm system that
went often sounded kind of like this their
whole giant sacred egg is obviously a version
of the actual dark Crystal they pay out that
whole bird Quaaludes joke when his crows rescue
him in exchange for drugs.
Like deal and deal.
You can all the Quaaludes you want Rick steals
their technology and the devolution gun.
Which is a huge deep cut like it is.
I'm keeping this.
But it's a reference to the awful awful live
action super Mario Brothers movie with Bob
Hoskins John leg was Imo and Dennis Hopper
as King Cuba during that movie.
They have the super Nintendo super scope guns
that they called the devolution guns that
would devolve creatures.
They also pay off the bird on a wire attack
joke destroying the crystal in the rest of
the birds they use the crows storyline the
payoff Morty and Rick's relationship.
Like he causes him to think more about the
nature of their relationship.
I love the way that crows seem like they're
more emotionally in touch with themselves
than Rick, which seems very on brand for Rick
when he goes back to help Morty he whips out
a device for hand regeneration in this cold
and nice and handy which is a reference to
a handjob which is hilarious.
Of course Rick would give his toys sexual
pun names with the options for different hands
that he could give them are a pirate hook
a lizard hand with clause a bird hand a horse
who and what it seems kind of like a duck
hand or like another animated character from another series
Then Rick reveals that he's gone full team
crowed to see what more they can teach them
these cosmic beings with the whole joke of
the spinoff show Rick into crows and does
of full version of the Rick and Morty rant
from the pilot episode and they did during
season three as well.
But even more over the top and he's done before
mostly to set up the opening scene for episode
10 for the finale also think they try to make
it seems so ridiculous and over the top the
you understand clearly that this is just a
joke and they're not actually creating the
specific spinoff show.
Rick then shows Morty that he trust him now
gives him his portal gun paying off their
argument from the beginning of the episode
in just to go through all the things that
he rants about so he says a thousand seasons.
This time when he says 14 episodes per season,
it's a response to the complaint early on
that originally Rick and Morty had plans to
14 episodes per season, but Dan and Justin
said that they rented production issues.
So they had a wind of doing 10 episodes per
season, and then he just turns into a big
tick-tock joke feeling you within the post
credit scene is them paying off the big garbage
Cooper joke with him being this Harvard educated
Doctor but being reduced to ricks trash bin
and not being able to break free of that relationship.
If you spotted any other Easter eggs during
episode nine that I didn't talk about during
the video just right them blown the comments
my full Rick and Morty Season 5 episode 10
finale video will post next in a couple hours.
So make sure you have alerts enabled for my
channel so you don't miss that.
Because it is a big evil Morty episode my
marvel what if episode five video will be
posting this Wednesday just like normal also
links for all those other videos out of the
description below.
Everyone click here for my Rick and Morty
season 5 episode 10 finale video will update
the link when I post that video later today
and click here for my marvel shang chi post
credit scene video.
Thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and I'll see you in the next video!